drug makers biontech and pfizer say
three shots of their coronavirus vaccine
are effective against the newly
discovered omicron variant biontec also
announced they could have a new omicron
specific vaccine
ready by march next year earlier the
world health organization said there is
no reason to expect that the existing
vaccines against the coronavirus will
fail against the omicron variant
let's take a listen exactly to what the
dwho's
emergencies director said moments ago
i would expect quite frankly that the
the vaccines we currently have will show
efficacy
against severe disease and
hospitalization but we have to measure
that and we have to confirm that that's
the case
all right like to welcome now to dw news
a molecular biologist ulrichia elling he
is with the austrian academy of sciences
in vienna a good day sir encouraging
news there from the who and biontech do
we know just how well vaccines protect
against this latest variant
now i i think we have to separate
different aspects here one is um
when we think of the pandemic and how to
manage it it's all about whether it
protects against infections
and
the data that we got from a lot of
scientists that work day night on this
today
are lab data so they
deal with how well this can be
neutralized but it really doesn't
answer us whether it protects against
infection
overall it looks like infection will not
be prevented by vaccination there's
enough of these case reports coming in
now we see increasing numbers all over
the place
but indeed it looks like a vaccination
might help against severe disease and
there it's really a question of whether
the glass is half empty or half full so
biontic and moderna are pointing out
that indeed three vaccinations the
booster works much better than two
but
you know they still work um
but but in many cases two vaccinations
just don't work as for example centered
c-section today now vaccine maker
biotech say they are developing omicron
specific boosters will vaccines have to
be altered every time that there is a
new variant on the scene
or and was this an expected development
well there was quite a bit of criticism
actually that they did not um already
adapt their vaccines to delta and we now
see that in fact you know it might have
been premature to take that decision
because it takes months and now we have
a variant where we probably will have to
adopt it we cannot adopt the um booster
to every new variant but if there is a
major change like the one we see now
then for sure this will be required
because we really see massive drop in
immunity
very briefly if you can
there's still a lot that we have to
figure out about this new variant as a
researcher yourself how do you go about
filling in the gaps what do we know
about omicron
the pandemic already has generated such
a
speed in the need for data that
researchers have mostly moved from
publishing peer-reviewed papers to
publishing so-called pre-prints so
non-peer-reviewed papers that they put
up in the open and that can be looked at
but now with omicron we actually see a
move away from the pre-prints to twitter
even such that researchers directly in
life share their data straight out of
the lab
and we're all trying to keep track of
what's going on and trying to provide
data as soon as possible this is an
urgent need now and it really has to be
said that the researcher that just that
managed to provide data now within just
a few days really since omicron was
identified
that is light speed and really
impressive so kudos to those people
kudos to those people brave new world
molecular biologist ulrich elling is
with the austrian academy of sciences
he's been speaking to us from vienna sir
thank you very much
you're welcome
you